always enjoyed this man's visit uh here
on the program
he was kind enough to send me an
advanced copy of his forthcoming memoir
reborn in the usa an englishman's love
letter to his chosen home
i'm wondering if there might now be some
sort of an addendum with the super
league being announced roger bennett of
men and blazers here on the rich eisen
show how are you roger
oh rich eisen hold me it's a dark and
terrible day
i wish i could know that you're totally
joking roger
but i know um it can you please describe
for this audience that may need some
sort of perspective
on what the hell has just happened and
why it has left so many people so
despondent
right i will do my best it's been a
harrowing historic seismic 24 hours
for global football yesterday there's of
12
of the biggest teams in europe announced
they were going to sign up for a
breakaway
super league funded by jp morgan
what it means is six of the biggest
clubs from england your manchester
united your liverpool's your chelsea's
three from italy in spain possibly a
couple of more still to be announced
reform
their own annual close competition from
an american perspective
it's a bit like you dukes in north
carolina kansas is being annoyed they
failed to qualify
for march madness and just announcing
they were going to have a breakaway
march madness of their own
in which they were guaranteed
participation every single year
when it does it's just destroying
everything that currently exists which
could possibly include the premier
league
and it's an enormous decision point for
global football i should say rich forced
in large part
by american owners along with that
oligarch and shake
counterpart it's a bit like if you
remember that old television show v
where we welcomed it the aliens to own
our football teams
and then were shocked and horrified when
they turned around and started to eat
english people
i do remember that uh i i and and so
v would be the american owners they
would be the
the uh they would be the you're cronkite
you'd love your stan cronkies you love
your glazes
you know the the the spanish teams
barcelona real madrid they've
their league is kind of melting down in
a pandemic so their self-interest in
doing this is
very clear the italian league has been
fading for a while so their teams their
big team to make sense for them to want
to jump in
but liverpool manchester united
um and and and and arsenal who are owned
by american sporting entrepreneurs
when you speak to them before this
occurred they were always shocked
at how an article english sport is
compared to american sport yet nfl
you know the teams play every year
there's a draft as a salary cap a rev
share it's all deeply controlled
the thing they loved about european
competition is that every time
every dollar of every shirt they sold
they didn't have to share that with the
other teams they could keep it all of it
but they're also freaked out by the
uncertainty you know four teams from
england every year
qualify for the champions league if you
have a hiccup in a season and miss that
your bottom line is totally uh
devastated so what they're looking for
is now their teams all have brand
prestige now that teams are global
billboards looking for certainty
looking for control and they're looking
for profits and they're looking to turn
european football into what the nfl is
which is a clues competition
with real certainty um even if it means
that the other teams all across europe
are ultimately financially kneecapped
well the uefa
um president um
said today that
the juventus chairman told him on
saturday there was nothing to this it
was just rumors and then turned his
phone off on him
called the executive vice chairman ed
woodward of manchester united a snake
saying that he told him last thursday
that he agreed to all the changes that
were coming for uefa and that all was
cool
um and then said that um
nobody that participates in this as a
player
could participate in the world cup how
does that work
is that possible and and what we're
really seeing is football
eating itself there is the the reaction
has been instant
and the media as a champions league is
the biggest tournament in europe
uh three of the breakaway teams are in
the semi-finals which uh
are eminem and you wait for a
threatening to expel them from this
year's competition
immediately the british government are
stepping into
here that should the the premier league
is one of the last vestiges of english
greatness i think we have
we have the royal family not doing so
well rich you may have noticed
downton abbey not coming back anytime
soon we have the
embers of the tweed industry of which
i'm one of the sole
uh lost great fans and we have the
english premier league
uh so none of these are in great shape
right now it's a massive financial
um powerhouse for britain the premier
league the government are stepping
in the media backlash is tremendous and
what's fascinating maybe from an
american perspective
is the fun backlash has been instant and
just
absolutely i mean there's been a
meltdown an american fans
are fine with being treated badly by
their owners i'm always shocked still
you know when crunky moves the same
lewis rams to
uh la you'll yeah that sport to business
that's how it works
um but the one group that the super
league team owners when they're in their
boardrooms in boston
tampa abu dhabi or wherever it is the
oligarchs keep their super yachts the
one group they've not thought about
as absentee landlords is the local fan
base
and the reaction has been instant and
enormous liverpool fans put a black
banner outside the stadium this morning
saying rest in peace liverpool
1892 to 2021 and take it from me rich i
know this from experience i grew up in
that fine city
and pissing off hundreds of thousands of
liverpudlians
it rarely ends well i mean you only have
to look a lot stuck into smoking barrels
to see what we have in store really is a
hell hello darkness my old friend said
roger bennett co-host along with michael
davies of men and blazers here on the
rich eisen show
so what is the aftermath because um
you know short of putting this into var
and hope for
a crazy result which might might be a
bad not be a bad idea
because anything that goes in there
usually comes up with the unexpected
um so what what what is the result here
do you really think that yeah
you know liverpool joins this this super
league
and and and money starts flowing in but
fans won't go
do you really think that fans would not
go or care one of the great seismic
um kind of tectonic plates in in global
football
is that there is a the english fans
generationally that the teams are still
houses of memory rich and they've
traveled with their teams every weekend
across england
uh they've traveled across europe
cheering for their teams but in modern
football money football
and the teams care less and less for
those local season ticket holders and
more and more for the global fan base
here in africa uh in across asia
and now this there's an incredible gold
rush for the
hearts and minds of the american fan and
that's always been the tension who are
the teams really playing to
all the fans now just the backdrop kind
of cat
like extras in a movie uh to engage the
global fan base and this is
ultimately they are making a bet that
the global fan base is more
the future than the local fan base there
is a chance this could all be a bluff
a power play to force the organizing
body in europe to
shape their competitions to provide more
money to the bigger teams
i don't think it is the owners i've
spoken to over the past 24 hours
have told me they are serious about
going forward with this contest and it
this is going to play out in the next
week incredibly fast incredibly brutally
at every level government
the football bureaucracy the media the
social media
will be nothing less than a sporting
civil war
and the question is will fans you know
we watch football for the
breathtaking poetry of a of a kevin de
bruyne or assist or a rose level dribble
or a lung bursting sheamus coleman run
up and down the when we watch for a
motion
and the moment this lead kicks off will
fans watch it that's ultimately the
question that
the team owners are betting that the
answer is yes and if boxing fans pay
money
to watch jake paul fight a patsy you
kind of feel sports fans will watch
anything and that's the bet that they're
making well i guess so
but you know these are some of the best
teams with the best players and of
course just
you know when uh a team usa could uh get
uh
christian pulisic on at a world cup you
know fresh off of his
uh dynamic runs at chelsea to be just
like everybody now
here to now he doesn't play because the
is that possible
is that feasible for position ultimately
the the big clubs are betting that
the leagues need them that the world cup
needs them more than they need the
leagues and wooden fifa
um yeah i'd need like a world cup
without the great players is what that's
really the bet that they're making
and ultimately you know we don't want to
see
how the sausages made it the football is
really the world's emotional this is the
darkness of what's happening that you
the the team owners are using the
pandemic as an excuse for
why they need to do it now just for
financial safety
and the pandemic never more than in this
moment
has football as a game brought such joy
you know it's bound the world together
when we watch these games we feel a
sense of connection we feel a sense of
emotion we feel alive and football the
game has really saved us
but the football industry in this moment
you realize the business can do the
opposite the myopia
the greed the selfishness the
self-interest
um and that's the the true darkness it's
gonna be the ultimately the fans and
uh and they that the court public
opinion in england i believe will
will uh will fight this one out there's
a tremendous anger there uh
how they've been uh kind of treated as
powerless
and many many fans it's a bit like what
they fell a bit like watching khaleesi
and their dragons burned down king's
landing
and how they react uh now coolly exposed
that the english fam will not want to
just be an innocent victim in all of
this
there's so much on the line for them in
terms of their love
their memories the proud the profound
connection
that they have with the game and that
ultimately is going to be
for one or lost in england rather than
the rest of the world so starting this
afternoon when liverpool play leads
watching that the fans reaction is going
to be ultimately definitive
so then before i let you go roger
bennett co-host of michael davies of the
men and blazers uh
here on uh on the rich eisen show so are
there
are there owners of i guess paris
saint-germain and uh
owners of i guess in in germany feeling
the pressure or
already said yeah but let me see how
let's see how the trial balloon goes you
take the first step and then there's
five other spots of qualifiers where do
they think that's coming from from
whatever's left of the embers of all the
the the leagues that that they're that
they're lopping the best teams off of
like seriously like they think they're
going to have a relationship with them
is that is that they said going to be
the new york cosmetics we'll put that
down for one
i'm not sure georgios are you saying
[ __ ] messing we're going to see him
in the net i mean my gosh
news rich eisen the um i don't think
that part has been particularly well
thought through i think that's going to
be a carrot
for other teams what is fascinating you
mentioned the german
teams german football clubs run off a
very different model to the rest of
uh the world they are predominantly fan
owned
and so the big teams there by an and
dormant who were both invited to join a
both put out statements saying that they
will refrain and in fact is everything
the euro
european super league that they don't
believe in and that's the battle right
now it is for the hearts and minds of
what
football um is truly about and i have to
believe
um your cronkies and your glazers
they've shown with arsenal they've shown
manchester united they genuinely could
not
care less for what the fan base think
and feel
i think ultimately the battlefield is
going to be liverpool football club
which is uh they are currently the
champions they are a owned by
fenway sports group uh john henry has
been incredibly sensitive to public
opinion in the past a couple of times
they've tried to float the notion of
radical change
in football the fan base has risen up
and they've
had a u-turn in terms of what they were
planning that liverpool team
i'm from liverpool happen to support the
other team like the mets to the yankees
football club that's full disclosure but
liverpool
it's a singular team liverpool is a is a
passionate town
it's a working-class town that football
team has been a totem of the city for
decades has represented it
out there in europe the the gentleman
who
who really founded the club bill shankly
a scottish trade unionist he
taught with great passion about how
liverpool was always going to be a
working man's club you walk through the
shankly gates
when you walk to a match at anfield
those fans it is a is a deeply committed
it's deeply passionate
and just watching the the the backlash
that's been instant towards the boston
red sox owners of liverpool
that that's the team to watch if they
stand up and just force this through
uh and lose that fan base it's an
incredibly delicate dance that they're
trying to do right now and i believe
that one
ultimately will determine the fate of
the future of european football
well roger i know you brought it up
before and i know this is not a
consolation at all and i don't say this
uh other than just to try and
set the facts straight this is not meant
in any other way to say that but
maybe lost amongst this super league
announcement certainly for you was that
downton abbey 2 has been set for
christmas the whole cast is
is coming back so there is that
to have mrs patmore back in my life rich
it's a tiny
solid but i want to say is a dark time
is a chaotic time
you know football does give us such joy
says sports has in lockdown
and to see the sport that we love almost
eat itself over the past 24 hours
personally not professionally
professionally i'm still very objective
but personally it's been it's been
bloody harrowing rich so it's great to
speak to you
right back at you roger again reborn in
the usa in englishman's love letter to
his chosen home a forthcoming memoir go
uh check it out where uh you can
maybe buy it prior to it's coming out
when it comes out i can't wait to
i can't wait to see the appendix or
whatever it is and uh
when you're whatever you might add to it
or whatever
whatever you might do from here on out
roger i'm always tuned into what you and
michael are up to
god speed rich eyes and then god bless
america correct
there you go roger bennett everybody
thanks roger follow him on twitter at
raj bennett my gosh
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here